as russia intensifies its war on ukraine
leaders from the u.s france turkey and
israel step up attempts to stop the
conflict does diplomacy still stand a
chance and what's needed for a
breakthrough this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo russia says its invasion of
ukraine could stop at any moment if kiev
agrees to its demands these include
recognizing crimea and breakaway regions
in eastern ukraine as russian
territories and as the war intensifies
world leaders are increasing their
diplomatic efforts the u.s secretary of
state has visited moldova and nato
allies poland lithuania and latvia
anthony blinken hinted at more sanctions
against russia including banning oil
imports he reminded president vladimir
putin of the price he's paying for
continuing the conflict
we see
the ruble going through the floor we see
russia's credit rating coming basically
to zero to junk status as we would call
it we see its stock market shut down we
see an exodus of virtually every leading
company
from russia
all of those things are happening
they're happening in real time at the
same time other steps that we've taken
including export controls on uh the most
important technology that russia needs
to modernize for the future including
its defense and aerospace industries
including its energy sector uh that
technology is being denied to russia
that's going to have a powerful impact
over time
meanwhile diplomatic efforts continue
turkey says the foreign ministers of
russia and ukraine will meet in antalya
later this week the leaders of france
and israel are talking to vladimir putin
as well frances emmanuel macron spent
two hours on the phone on sunday urging
the russian president to end military
operations and protects ukraine's
nuclear sites and israel's prime
minister naftali bennett made a secret
trip to moscow on saturday before
meeting germany's chancellor in berlin
jonah hall has more from live in western
ukraine
several world leaders have dipped their
toes into increasingly murky diplomatic
waters in recent days uh on the weekend
president emmanuel macron of france held
his fourth phone call with vladimir
putin in the kremlin since the invasion
began on february the 24th the pair
spent an hour and 45 minutes talking on
the phone on sunday president macron is
said to have urged putin to uphold
humanitarian law and to respect the
safety of ukraine's nuclear sites
naftali bennett the israeli prime
minister took off on a secret flight to
moscow on the weekend spending three
hours with mr putin in the kremlin
before then heading off for further
talks with the german government in
berlin
but the phone call that has produced the
most information for us about what
president putin is currently thinking
took place on sunday between him and
president erdogan of turkey mr erdogan
urged putin to declare a ceasefire to
open humanitarian corridors and to sign
a peace agreement and he offered turkey
as a host for talks that was from the
turkish side in response the kremlin
says mr putin said the only way out of
this war is if ukraine surrenders its
weapons and guarantees all of the
kremlin's demands those to remind you uh
include not just the full military
surrender of ukraine but also guarantees
about its neutrality that it will never
become a member of nato mr putin also
wants crimea to be recognized as part of
russia after its annexation in 2014 and
he wants recognition of the independence
of those breakaway regions in the east
mr putin reportedly said that russia's
war goals were on track for being met
and he said he hoped that ukrainian
negotiators ahead of talks due to
continue this week would approach those
talks in a more quote constructive
manner
so can diplomacy ultimately bring an end
to the conflict in ukraine let's bring
in our guests for today's show in moscow
we have andre fedorov who served as
deputy foreign minister of russia and is
the chairman of the fund for political
research and consulting in russia in
brussels carol lannu chief executive of
the center for european policy and
studies and in doha marwan kabalan head
of policy analysis at the arab center
for research and policy studies thank
you all gentlemen for joining us on
inside story andrei fedorov in moscow
let me start with you the two sides
russia and ukraine have engaged in a
couple of rounds of discussions
bilaterally but russia has not passed
its military operations in ukraine
is the kremlin
at all interested in diplomacy
of course kremlin is interested in
diplomacy but the problem is that
during this recent context
which took place
there is one obstacle
russia formulated very clearly
a number of demands which are
unacceptable for ukrainian side and
that's why uh
during this diplomatic context we can
more or less agree only on some
humanitarian issues but all the main
political issues are left unsolved
and there are very few chances they can
be solved in the way
like putin wants it what is president
putin's thinking andrei i mean what's
his decision-making process and do you
think he's willing to make any
compromises on on some of the red lines
he said he wouldn't cross
no i don't think that
in case of ukraine uh he will
he's absolutely not ready for compromise
uh he put a very clear goal for himself
uh this uh as he mentioned
recently that if there will be no
agreement uh of ukraine on our demands
ukraine might lose its statehood
so it's a very clear line and that's why
we cannot expect that the military
operation might stop soon okay so you
don't expect the military operation to
stop soon marwan kambalan in doha let me
bring you in now a lot of actors in this
crisis trying to push for diplomacy
turkey's foreign minister has announced
that the foreign ministers of russia and
ukraine will meet in antalya later this
week could there be a breakthrough you
think does diplomacy still stand a
chance
in in your view in this crisis
no i don't think i don't think so i
don't think diplomacy is having any
chance
at this particular stage
uh in making any any progress i think
president putin is using negotiation
while actually he is
also using military force on the ground
with pressure on the ukrainians to get
the concessions
uh he wanted from the very beginning i
think he
uh
he's trying to
put as much pressure
as possible on the ukrainian government
uh most important for him perhaps
is to
get
[Music]
the concession that
makes ukraine
that makes ukraine
be not but of nato
and also to disarm to disarm the country
uh all together so i don't think that
the diplomacy is having any chance right
now okay so let me come to you now then
uh in brussels uh carol lannu andre in
moscow says the military operation will
continue marwan kabalan says he doesn't
think diplomacy stands a chance do you
see any avenue for de-escalating this
conflict or any possible ways to end the
crisis diploma diplomatically
very limited chances certainly since so
much damage has been done at the
ukrainian side as well in civil as a
military term so much damage also has
been done in material terms to buildings
through roads
etc in ukraine i think the hostility has
simply increased from where it was say
two weeks three weeks ago so i think
it's extremely difficult to come to a
diplomatic solution
anyway the eu is trying to have a form
of diplomatic solution with all the
sanctions it has imposed let's say not
military yeah but sanctions carl
sanctions alone haven't been enough
to make putin uh pause the invasion and
bring him to the negotiation negotiating
table and the humanitarian crisis as
we're seeing is is worsening the
conflict escalating
you know is is europe considering other
diplomatic options are they other uh
solutions on the table as far as the
europeans and nato is concerned
there are even people now considering
let's say to end all kinds of imports
from gas and oil from russia at the
moment but of course that causes the
problem to say how well would you place
it because
the dependency on gas and oil and
imports for energy in european countries
differs enormously but if you look only
at the baltic states it's a hundred
percent dependence on
gas and oil from russia so it is
extremely difficult you cannot replace
this overnight on the other hand with
regards to sanctions like the financial
sanctions essentially against the banks
sanctioned against the oligarchs you
will only see the effects after a few
days or after a few weeks or after a few
months when the russian economy comes on
its fees right but those are those are
sticks
right i mean the europeans all we've
seen from europe right now are sticks
are there any carrots they could offer
right now to moscow uh why should they
offer a carrot to moscow as most people
started this conflict i just don't know
let's say what kind of
concession they should make to
moscow and not even infuriating
um ukraine more we see already there's
the whole debate about the no-fly zone
but where ukraine would like to have a
no-fly zone towards the western side but
of course uh putin has said no way we
can we can do this so and then zelansky
is saying look that is impossible i'd
say europe must help us but europe is
extremely afraid to be involved much in
this conflict which risks escalating
into an overall european war right andre
fedorov let me put that question to you
that uh car just asked why should europe
and nato offer any carrots to moscow
right now
oh i don't think that there is a chance
for any carrot but i think there will be
more and mistakes stakes
as far as i mentioned previously
there are very few chance that the
military operation
will
be stopped because
putin
has very clear
picture
in front of him you want
zelinski and
the government of ukraine to resign
he wants to
bring new government he wants to change
the constitution to make uh
ukraine
out of any military blocks
for this you need a referendum of course
and of course he needs what he calls
demilitarization of ukraine and the
nazification of ukraine which is both
are very very difficult
okay well gentlemen let's take a closer
look at some of the mediators in this
conflict now
france currently holds the rotating
presidency of the european union before
the invasion president macron took part
in negotiations that led to the minsk
agreement to secure a ceasefire in
eastern ukraine
turkey has good political and economic
ties with both ukraine and russia ankara
called the invasion unacceptable but
opposes sanctions against moscow it also
sold drones to ukraine angering the
kremlin
israel also has long established ties
with both countries about 200 000 jews
live in ukraine and some have already
fled to israel as refugees and israel
relies on the kremlin to help coordinate
security in syria it also wants russia's
support for a tougher stance against
iran's nuclear program
marwan caballon let me come to you and
talk about israel first an unexpected
player an unexpected new player in this
crisis at least we saw prime minister
nathalie bennett fly to moscow hold
talks with vladimir putin
what can israel bring to the table is
israel a potent mediator in this crisis
well i mean
i don't i don't feel like the israelis
or the turks or anybody
else actually
can
bring any diplomatic solution to the
crisis at this at this stage but the
israelis are trying actually to play to
play a role in all of this because they
are having uh
good relations with both with both
ukraine and russia
and they are on the other hand trying to
evade the pressure from the united
states to take more aggressive position
towards towards russia
israel
as you said i mean is having
a vested interest in keeping the
cooperation with russia and syria
because the russians are allowing the
israelis actually to go after the
iranians
in in that country but on the other hand
they are having also
very good ties with the ukrainian
president zielinski
some of zielinski closed advisors
closest advisors actually are having uh
israeli citizenship and israel is also
interested in
protecting the jews of ukraine during
this military operation by by russia so
i think i think israel could also be
trying here in marwan to to have some
leverage on the iran nuclear deal given
that russia is involved in those
negotiations
absolutely and i think
the israelis must have received very
positively the news yesterday when the
russians they demanded that
their trade relationship with iran not
be affected by the u.s sanctions if they
are to uh to go with the
revival of the nuclear with the nuclear
deal with with iran so i think um this
is something came like uh like a gift
out of the blue for the israelis uh and
they are
they believe that uh it might still be
possible for uh for the necklace to be
to be somehow derailed yeah uh so of
course i mean they have this interest
with with russians carol lano in
brussels french president emmanuel
macron has kept
an open communication line with vladimir
putin he's only he's one of the very few
western leaders who's done so
how can he make a difference you think
and can he make a difference does put
does he have convincing
uh you know a convincing method i mean
probably the only convincing method
which macro has is that france is the
biggest military power in europe
and
putin only listens to power
but i think that's the only thing
because i don't think there's a lot of
support at the moment in europe let's
say for the talking grounds which macron
has got
with putin over the last weeks and which
has yielded
no effect i mean we know that say that
putin listens almost to nobody probably
only too few of us military so that's
why i wonder why
macron is going there on top of that
what i see is that macron is he
coordinating with other european
partners i think he does so but that's
not really he's not a missionary of
europe he's the missionary of france so
we need to have a person who goes there
let's say to speak on behalf of all the
europeans
and of course
the same wavelengths when it comes to to
uh how to deal with putin are they all
agreeing that these sanctions is what
they should be uh doing and that what
they should insist on
that's for sure and i think europeans
are we even be willing to do much more
if you see what poland is doing at the
moment but of course the poland the
polish haiti the russians we know this
is a long time but overall if you see
the um the manifestations which we've
got in many european capitals over the
last say like this weekend but over the
last weeks it's clear that there's a
strong support to take a very hard line
against russia okay let me ask you uh
andre in moscow
about something carl just said there
does president putin listen to anyone
you know who would be a credible
mediator to him in this crisis right now
we saw the israeli prime minister in
moscow could israel be
uh
you know a good broker in this crisis as
far as russia no i don't think so though
uh it was uh
president zielenski who
at the first stage of the conflict who
proposed to make uh
context via israel
because zelensky himself is a jew and
has very good relations
but uh
the problem is that for putin he doesn't
want any kind of broker uh between him
and ukraine
the problem is that
putin doesn't want to have a peace deal
i mean in traditional way of
understanding of this
term
but he wants a
capitulation of ukraine
he wants uh step down or zelensky and
that's why uh
no broker no no one knows that side uh
can uh
bring all these things to compromise
this is the difficulty and concerning
macron i think okay it's my personal
opinion but i think all his trips on his
talks are absolutely senseless
uh because uh he cannot play any serious
role and
also because
i might say so because i've been in kf
recently i know the situation he's not
very much respected in ukraine in
ukrainian leadership that's why he is
not the the guy who can make
some kind of agreement etc etc
okay uh what are your thoughts about
that uh carl lanu uh
you know andre says putin doesn't want a
peace deal so where do we go from here
nato insists that ukraine's a sovereign
country we should have the right to
decide whether it wants to be uh in nato
or not i mean how how do we move on from
this yeah very difficult to know i mean
i think it will be what we need to do
with europeans is give all the help
support moral support to the ukrainian
army to the ukrainian people at this
stage at the maximum possible without
interfering into the war without opening
this war to become a european or world
war and that is of course at the moment
a problem but we all
know that say that already today ukraine
has won the
uh the communication
campaign about this war and also ukraine
has done much more damage to the russian
military than we than the russians has
ever expected so once the bad news gets
out into russia how bad this war is
advancing for the russians right it
could change the picture for uh for uh
putin very rapidly carl i wanted to ask
you about the the nato issue why is that
so difficult for europe and and uh nato
to compromise on the issue of ukraine
acceding to nato does sovereignty mean
that a country
is free to make its own decision
irrespective of the security of others i
mean would the u.s for example allow
mexico to have a security deal a
security alliance or military alliance
with uh russia or china for example
probably not certainly the u.s would not
allow mexico to have a landline so we've
so why should the ukrainians be
be allowed to be part of nato
if that's the main concern
because for russia that would be a
direct challenge and that's how it's
been seen over the last 10 or 12 years
let's say after the discussion in 2008
when there was a possibility or some
groups were advocating under the bush
administration for ukraine to become a
member of nato we have seen that for the
nato to defend
ukraine against that aggression of
russia like today would be almost
impossible because ukraine is such a
large country which is also
geographically positioned very far
towards the east of course there is the
western part which is close to poland
czechoslovakia slovakia and czech
republic for example but there is the
the other part which is very far to the
east and that is a problem for uh for
europe how could we defend for europe
and the nato how could we defend the
country which is so far to the east for
example take the crim
anyway we have seen now the question
also of georgia georgia asking for
membership of the eu which also raise
the question of membership possible
membership eventually of nato as well
can we can the eu go so far east but i
would say this is one of the positive
very difficult to say positive
developments of the this crisis is that
the support for europe and the support
for the eu has grown enormously and only
two weeks well let's talk about turkey
marwan kabalan another country which was
supposed to be part of the european
union but it's not turkey playing its
card in this complex situation very
closely uh what can turkey bring to the
table given its relations with both
ukraine and russia and what do you think
is needed for a breakthrough here
i think they can bring very little in my
opinion as your previous guest said
president putin will not accept but
regime change in in ukraine
uh and also getting all the guarantees
that this country will not be part of
near to any time in the
in the future the turks actually because
they have they are having also distant
interest in this conflict they don't
want actually russia to prevail in
ukraine because uh if the russians uh
takes uh the
the the most of the cost of the of the
black sea that will will be uh
negatively impacting the the security of
of turkey but on the other hand turkey
would like actually to keep its uh
working relationship with with russia
that one has been developed especially
in in syria but they are having also
competitions in many other
places uh like in libya and in
in caucasia
so the turks here are trying on one hand
to keep their relationship with turkey
with russia because we all know also
that they are having very important
economic relationship with with russia
the trade balance between the two
countries uh this year's expect last
year actually was like 30 billion
dollars and it is expected actually to
rise okay uh so i think they are they
are on one hand trying to have this
relationship keep this relationship with
russia but on the other hand they have
a strong relationship also with ukraine
and they are arming ukraine actually by
by turkish thrones let me ask you
gentlemen one last question to each one
of you and very briefly if you can
starting with you andre in moscow what
is needed
for a breakthrough in this crisis
i can see only one way is a personal
meeting between putin and zelensky
this is the only way uh how the things
might happen
but there are very very few chances less
than 20
that this meeting can take place okay uh
your thoughts carol lanu would a
personal meeting between zielinski uh
and putin uh
make any progress
i wonder for the because of the
hostility between both and what
certainly what putin has said about
zielinski already about the whole kind
of uh
ukrainian administration so far but i
think let's say what could change a bit
of the picture but also very low
probabilities if the chinese were to
take a very strong position of what is
going on
it remains very improbable
were to take a position where he manages
to tamper a bit the feelings of putin
that may make a change all right marwan
kabalan in doha what could change you
think
well i think i think a meeting between
putin and joe biden might actually
change things i don't think between
putin and zelinski is is going to do
anything i think putin is mainly
interested in in the united states and
in u.s
reaction in this crisis because we all
know now he's concerned that the us
might turn ukraine into a quagmire uh
afghanistan number two for russia that
is very possible uh so i think only a
meeting between the two the two big
powers could actually uh
make a breakthrough in this case so more
talks more meetings needed thank you
very much gentlemen for a very
interesting discussion andre fedorov
carl lanu and marwan kabalan
and thank you for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can of
course also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me fuli batiboy and the whole team
here in doha thanks for watching bye for
now
[Music]